herzlich zu diesem video leute heute ist
es endlich soweit ich bin so krank
aufgeregt wie alle von euch wissen bin
ich unfassbar verrückt nach allem was
von einem motor angetrieben wird
deswegen habe ich auch dieses auto
format auf einem kanal was vielleicht
nicht so viele wissen ist dass ich im
letzten jahr meinen motorradführerschein
gemacht habe also ich darf jetzt die
klasse a unbeschränkt und darf jetzt
alle motorräder fahren unabhängig von
der leistung und es ist soweit leute ich
habe mir mein erstes eigenes motorrad
gekauft bevor sich alles weitere erzähle
leute aber jetzt mal ganz wichtige info
denn ich habe eine ultra geile
kooperation mit amazon prime video am
star das ganze dreht sich um die serie
panic die jetzt neu bei amazon prime
video also wenn ihr gerne serien steckt
ja auch die ganze kooperation ist aber
so nice weil ihr meine community was
gewinnen könnt ich bin nämlich gegen ein
kumpel von mir alex lx wie angetreten
einer challenge und habe preise für euch
ihr spielt unter anderem ist dann in den
tempo switch dabei die ihr genau jetzt
ganz ganz ganz easy gewinnen können
leute das erfahrt ihr wenn ihr auf den
ersten link in dem die beschreibung
klickt oder bis zum ende dran bleibt und
auf den button der das video verlinkt
hat am ende dass das video auf dem
videokanal macht auf jeden fall mit
leute easyad kann man an neuen meistens
darf nicht kommen jetzt weiter mit dem
video und wir sehen uns am ende des
videos nach letztes jahr hatte ich schon
mal leihweise für ein paar monate ducati
die wir auch richtig pressure partie
nochmal aber jetzt ist es so weit ich
habe mir einfach mein eigenes bike
gekauft ich habe so lange mit mir
gerungen habe ich das machen sollen dass
so viel geld ist aber ich habe jetzt
einfach mal gemacht weil manchmal muss
man einfach die sachen machen die einem
so freude geben und es ist weit leute
das bei kommt jedem moment an ich würde
sagen wir springen direkt mal zur
abholung alter zu tun
[Musik]
das war schon ein paar kleine
ausschnitte leute und jetzt zeige ich
sie euch endlich ausführlich meine
yamaha xfr 902 das denke ich so ein
bisschen schmutzig story dafür einfach
das wetter so harmlosen kölner valriche
guckt euch das mal an hier stets xr 900
dieser tank bruder logic ich finde für
die leute die die x100 als bei kennt
dieser colorway ist der schönste der
schönsten theater sieht aus wie eine
zigarettenschachtel aus den achtzigern
ich rauche nicht mehr aber trotzdem ist
einfach sooo geil ist einfach so schön
aber auch gerade diese goldenen felgen
sehr exotisch ja das sieht aber das
passt sogar ihr seht ihr schon dass es
zu wissen so eine retro bald auch für
retro optik stimmt aber das geht ab wie
lucy no job das ist so schnell 116 ps
und 780 newtonmeter dreizylinder ich
will gar nicht viel erzählen ist so viel
wie alex g8 ja genau ich mein motorrad
zu viel zylinder wie alex auto nur noch
von alex sollte ist wird euch gar nicht
sagen kommt man hier rundherum bilde mir
ist ja hallo lieber auf ins erfolgen
falls es nicht tut macht sofort mein
erstes kennzeichen a ber 34 ist mir
einfach abgefallen
auf einer fahrt also musste ich noch mal
von köln aachen wird und noch mal neues
geld besorgen
jetzt haben wir abs 6 869 werd ich noch
besser wir sollen wir uns was ihr hier
seht heute ist kein stand auspuff das
ist ein mix racemag 2 und er hat eine
richtig fetten klang fünf vielleicht
nicht nicht rein
ja genau
let's go
siemens will
jung das ist der sound der anzug in
optik ich bin so happy damit läuft für
euch noch dieses bike hatte ich nicht
neu gekauft das kostet 19.600 ich hab's
elf monate alt mit ganz wenig kilometern
für 91 bekommen inklusive auspuffanlage
die 800 euro selbst kostet oder so
inklusive neuer bremshebel neue spiegel
also kaufte wirklich autos motorräder am
besten wenn es wenn sie teurer sind auf
die am besten ein 23 jahre alt gerade
autos so viel geld und die sind noch
fast wie neu kann ich euch nur raten
aber ist es so sexy alter bin so halt
leute in new york ich konnte nicht mehr
schlafen die tage davor aber ja ich
würde sagen dann eine offene fahrt
jetzt wäre ob der bis jetzt regnet dann
hast gott nicht wirklich alle gucken was
das für ein typ hat ein programm hin
[Musik]
das schmeckt sagt anke auch nach der so
bereit broda der ist so breit dass hat
man sieht man auf bildern nicht aber der
so fucking breit dieses bike ist nicht
so schlank wie es aussieht
after market aus schondra nix race war
allerdings dafür interessieren hab das
schon so gebraucht gekauft ortega sogar
die kopf frisch auch diese krise so früh
habe ich mir die ganze treppe
einfach mit der hand hält festigkeit des
kennzeichens die so noch mal zu machen
es wird einfach flagge und es schmeckt
nicht schmeckt als nasse straßen neues
bleibt muss man höllisch aufpassen leute
da muss man höllisch aufpassen dass ich
bin ein vorsichtiger fahren muss ich
sagen deswegen die bremsen gehen auch
daran dass ich zu hause geil an gas
ich merke dass schon etc statt natürlich
nicht viele die so geehrten gab es merkt
dass sofort das geil perfekt und dann
vor sich einen zeh 200 kompressor zu
haben
immerhin kennt jetzt hier wird hat man
der fahrschule gelernt beute
kopfsteinpflaster und das ganz besonders
aufpassen aber physisch immer gut an das
projekt an kämpfe zwischen den beiden
schaltung da muss man sich erst dran
gewöhnen
jetzt beugt das hier ist es höchste
glitschig das war soweit die vorstellung
von meinem bike leute ich bin wirklich
im siebten himmel ich finde es so
unfassbar geil das ist endlich da ist
man richtig happy was lange gedanken
dazu schreibt man dass man die
kommentare rein und ganz ganz ganz
wichtig checkt jetzt hier das video auf
dem amazon prime videokanal ab in der
infobox es in der beschreibung von dem
video findet ihr alle informationen die
er braucht um ganz ganz easy für euch
was zu gewinnen und das meiner stelle
[Musik]